сержант бро інших сил України Віталій
гранкін по трапу
впав він поруччя військам 24 серпня минуло
бураку додому обернувся виступати свої
звивини nevian важа я щасливий випад
до вісті
тобто топ то там не травня такого шляху
читку за списком ще голову якісь
такі щось йдуть naumen
admins та лотерея не споживав лікар
сплески а лікарі по стежках до будинку через
70 днів
потрапив додому через 70 днів.
плани на повз і так і хаотичний характер
чому він часто зривається на тип це не я
дочку вбили й українська служба bespeco
так званого повного дружина днр зомбі на
повний і на моє вбрання вивів і голову
обміркувати коріння не потім he царський
корпус володимир рубан травня статус тури
мовано до вигляду крафіни вин місто повія у
сирійського конфлікту на донбасі та мовляв
вона стоїть шахту потрібно крем того
ви канати ви можуть так званих днр і лнр
щоб зрушувати їх активістів
я як званого вшивати про сепаратизм
тероризмі у швидких практично не чоловікові
його за супер відшити закону і чи буде
прокурор рик і ух valeo таке рішення
грішну може сам забійно на цьому засланні
фліп pu
українські чиновники йдучи на зустрічці
чиновники обожнюють звір малюю з плену
випускаються проти сепаратистів і про
тему пак і криється легким, бо займаючись
людину на я лідирую закону і менше
керівництво буквою закону ніби
amnesty ти хто в червні на боті сама
прогулянкових днр та лнр сепаратисти
ставити піцу мені в обмін всіх на всіх
з чуприна веж і мінським і думу владою
повного разом з апарати стіни Петро йому
та бама тахту в Україні засіки
міжнародно-правових підставах зайця та
разом international
плани на ebay скуто але поки що точно то
що колиба на видути вайаніді не
з точки за міжнар на право c але
тоді ви починаєте б фст ось так то ось
ось так ось таким чином можна їх
політику від сепаратисти мають бути пу
корані
закривається на жовтець залишення до
українських ризиково полунин їх вpn і на
Віталій вигляд у цій своїй здоровій їжі
вираз з повний у чилавика дасин і
може і державою окатиш вид на вигляд я
затягну стежки височіють жан там у тему йому
а жіньяк треба допомагаю